Welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof.
Hello Martin. How are you today? I am
well and you alter.
I'm getting better. Thank you.
It's good.
You sound better. You look
fit.
Do I look fit?
Well.
Alive.
We going on and carrying on.
There's no stopping now. We're on the
home stretch. Oh, thank goodness for
that. Let's open with a word of prayer.
Our heavenly father, we thank you once
again bringing us together.
Lord, we want to discuss some important
topic.
And we want you to help us please
enlightening our minds with the Holy
Spirit and guiding this discussion. In
Jesus' name we ask. Amen. Amen.
Well Martin.
Ancient Israel wasn't perfect, right?
No, not at all.
And I read in the spirit of prophecy
that we excel ourselves and outdo them.
Yeah, just for in case you think oh, but
we would never have done that.
Yes, exactly. So Martin, if that is the
case, if we outdo them, then we can
learn a lot from the history
of Israel.
Isn't the don't the Bible say that
they
it was written for our admonition. Yes.
Those things were written for us and for
our time.
Now after last week's what's up
where we spoke about
some of the
thinking patterns in our beloved church.
There are so many people that think, you
know, are we still on the right ship?
So I thought it was important that we
discuss a little bit about the remnant
today.
Because some people have the starry-eyed
perception of
perfection in the remnant. But that's
not biblical because the remnant is
Laodicea.
And it is blind, pitiful, poor,
wretched, naked. I mean, those are quite
a few choice words
describing the church.
Just for in case you think you're you've
arrived,
Yeah. just read that portion again.
Nevertheless,
the church is the apple of his eye.
So let's have a look at some of these
issues so that people don't think, you
know, we are just negative.
We have to be positive within a sphere
of negativeness.
That's true.
And this might also answer the question
because that you get people that say I
don't want to belong to any
denomination. I don't want to belong to
a church.
Many, many people don't want to belong
to a denomination and many people have
been church hopping.
They hop from one to another
and then they find this and then they
find that. You also get the
people that say I'm a follower of Jesus.
That's my church. That's the church,
yes. But then you'd have to, you know,
join every church because they all claim
the same thing. You see that puts you
into the ecumenical
part of the church.
And I think this will make some portions
of that clear.
Well, let's hope so. Let's look at some
of these issues.
We cannot start something like this
without looking at Peter's confession,
the great confession.
And of course it's in Matthew chapter 16
and because it's so important, there's a
massive church
that misuses it
and misapplies it
and
turns the glory towards man ex-
rather than where it should belong,
right? With Jesus.
So when Jesus came into the coast of
Caesarea Philippi,
he asked his disciples saying, "Who do
men say that I, the son of man, am?"
And they said, "Some say thou art John
the Baptist,
some Elias, and others Jeremias or one
of the prophets."
He said unto them, "But whom say ye that
I am?"
This is why it's so important
that in the King James you have the
thee, thou, etc. It says ye. That's
plural.
So he's addressing all of them.
What do you say? No, yeah, he wasn't
just talking to Peter.
No, he wasn't just talking to Peter.
But Simon Peter is the one who answered
and Simon Peter answered and said, "Thou
art the Christ, the son of the living
God."
That's the great confession.
The realization of who are you dealing
with.
God manifest in the flesh.
And Jesus answered and said unto them,
"Blessed art thou, Simon Bar-Jonah,
for flesh and blood has not revealed it
unto thee, but my father which is in
heaven."
So this is a a divine implant.
So without a divine implant, you will
not be able to accept this truth.
And I say also unto thee, "Thou art
Peter,
and Peter means pebble.
And upon this rock
I will build my church and the gates of
hell shall not prevail against it."
So now there are two ways of
interpreting this, of course, as the
world does. Peter is the rock
or the great confession, the statement
that he just made is the rock on which
the church is built.
Obviously, it must be the latter.
Because if we had to build the church on
Peter,
it would be a catastrophe.
True. Mhm. Because then it's on human
It's on on human devising. Now, Peter
turned out well,
but the road to well was paved with good
intentions sometimes misapplied, right?
Same with us. That's true. If if at this
stage Jesus was meant meant that he was
building it upon Peter,
just after this Peter fell. Exactly.
So there already you can see that it
couldn't be on Peter. No. So
the the church is built on the great
confession.
And namely,
"Thou art the Christ, the son of the
living God." That's the bottom line.
And the gates of hell shall not prevail
against it.
The church. Because he mentions it
by name.
Now Peter Peter came and Peter went.
And everyone else down the stream of
history came and went. So it cannot be
built on a human.
It has to be built on the divine.
So the gates of hell shall not prevail
against it. Is Christianity still there?
Yes.
Has it been perverted to a great extent?
Yes. Can the truth still be found?
Definitely.
Aha. So the gates of hell haven't
prevailed against it.
Because surely the devil tried to
obliterate it. Oh, definitely.
And he tried in different ways. First
with physical and then in a spiritual
way.
Now the next question is, why does the
Lord permit
such terrible deteriorations
as you had in the Middle Ages?
And then you have a new start and a
fresh move and new strength and there
you go and the reformation and 500 years
later,
where are they? Back with Rome.
Back with Rome, right?
The Anglican church and the Oxford
movement
under their so-called Cardinal Newman
brought the mass back, brought the
statues back, brought the liturgy back.
And when he'd done his baleful work,
off he went to the Vatican and became a
cardinal. Mhm. Mhm.
Whenever he was in trouble, Martin,
whenever they thought he might be a
Jesuit because of what he was writing
and what he was doing,
he would bring a rousing this Cardinal
Newman. Yeah.
Stating that the Pope is the Antichrist
and he's so evil and everybody would
say, "Well, he must be okay if he still
thinks thinks the Pope is the
Antichrist." But once the job was done,
off he went
and became a cardinal in the Catholic
Church. We have to be aware for such of
such tactics, don't we, Martin? Yeah,
beware of those smooth um sermons and
And then you ask yourself the question,
why does the Lord not intercede?
Why does he not
correct it? Why does he allow it to go
down that slippery slope
to the point of almost no return?
But then we must remember that the gates
of hell will not will not prevail
against it. Well, the answer, of course,
is also here in Peter, 2 Peter 3:9, "The
Lord is not slack concerning his promise
as some men count slackness,
but is long-suffering towards not
willing that any should perish, but that
all should come to repentance."
Uh will all come to repentance?
No, unfortunately not. But he's not
willing to let them perish.
He is still so long-suffering
that he will for the last one prevail
it.
So, he permits it in
shall we say the hope, if we think in
human terms,
that they might see their error and turn
from their ways.
That's one way of looking at at it.
The other is, of course, that even in
spite of all the evidence, if they do
not turn and repent,
they will have no excuse. That's true.
And eventually, at the end,
when he has decided no further,
then it will also be that anybody that
questions that will be
uh proved he will God will be proved
that he did everything he could in his
power to save humanity.
Well, here's a quote from the Acts of
the Apostles, "From the beginning,
God has been working by his Holy Spirit
through human instrumentalities
for the accomplishment of his purpose in
behalf of the fallen race.
This was manifest in the lives of the
patriarchs.
To the church in the wilderness also in
the time of Moses, God gave his good
spirit to instruct them, Nehemiah 9:20.
And in the days of the apostles, he
wrought mightily for his church through
the agency of the Holy Spirit.
The same power that did sustain the
patriarchs,
that gave Caleb and Joshua faith and
courage, and that made the work of the
apostolic church effective,
has upheld God's faithful children in
every succeeding age.
It was through the power of the Holy
Spirit that during the Dark Ages, the
Waldensian Christians helped to prepare
the way for the Reformation.
It was the same power that made
successful the efforts of noble men and
women
who pioneered the way for the
establishment of modern missions and for
the translation of the Bible into the
languages and dialects of all nations
and peoples."
So, Martin, this is what it's been like
ever since God has had a witness on this
earth.
And you know, I read something about
Moses that I found intriguing.
And it comes from Testimonies, volume
four.
Perhaps I can read that.
It says here on page 611,
"The burden of God's work laid upon
Moses made him a man of power.
While keeping for so many years the
flocks of Jethro, he gained an
experience that taught him true
humility.
Now, here comes the interesting part.
But God's call found Moses as it will
find us."
In case you've got a big head, Martin.
Let me read that again. "God's call
found Moses as it will find us,
inefficient,
hesitating,
self-distrustful.
Oh, no, I can't do this. I'm not going
to do this. No, no, no.
Uh this is for someone else to do.
The command to deliver Israel seemed
overwhelming, but in the fear of God,
Moses accepted the trust. Mark the
result.
He did not bring the work down to his
deficiency,
but in the strength of God, he put forth
the most earnest effort to elevate and
sanctify himself for his sacred
mission."
So, Martin, how important is it
that we put forth an earnest effort to
elevate and sanctify ourselves
for God's sacred mission?
Without it, you cannot do his sacred
mission. Okay. And he is doing the work.
You will you have to be willing.
He continues, "Moses would never have
been prepared for his position of trust
had he waited for God to do the work for
him."
How many people
are there that say, "When the time
comes,
Yeah. then God will make the way
straight."
It don't work that way.
to be willing
and put your foot forward into the
Jordan.
Yes.
Lights from heaven will come to those
who feel the need of it.
And who seek for it as for hidden
treasure. But if we sink down into a
state of inactivity,
willing to be controlled by Satan's
power, God will not send his inspiration
to us unless we exert to the utmost
the powers which he has given us,
we shall ever remain weak and
inefficient."
And then the recipe,
"Much prayer,
most vigorous exercise of the mind
are necessary
if we would be prepared to do the work
which God has entrusted to us."
"All who are fitted for usefulness in
this life must be trained by the
severest
mental and moral discipline.
And then God will assist them by
combining divine power with human
effort."
Martin, is it time that we take these
words seriously? Definitely.
And if you want to put it bluntly, it's
then time to start studying what God has
in store for you in the word. Yes, and
if you say, "But that was written for
then," as we did discuss last time,
you might just seriously miss the boat,
right? You see, that's where
uh modern criticism, uh what do you call
that?
Higher criticism.
Higher criticism. That's where that
comes in. And it totally destroys what
the Bible actually has to mean to today
to us. Exactly. If you if you neglect
the typologies,
if you put everything into the past,
well, then let's eat and drink and be
merry. That's it. Even if you put that
through to our modern-day prophet,
you've got the same problem. Same
problem. Once you start marginalizing
and putting it aside or putting it into
the past,
finding an excuse not to do what has
been said, then you're not only harm
yourself, but all those around you.
Yes. That is the problem, right?
Now, I listened to a talk the other day
about whether this church, the Adventist
Church, should still be considered a
cult or not.
And of course, they discussed Walter
Martin and all of these issues and what
he thought in the beginning and what he
thought in the end.
And uh
they were so knowledgeable and so wise
about everything. Walter Martin, he's
not spoken picking about me and you.
No, he's not speaking about me and him,
but it's an interesting
combination there.
And of course, they know everything
about Ellen White and what she what she
said and everything that she said that
was wrong, but they don't mention a
single one because they can't. Exactly.
Right?
And I was wondering, you know, how
interesting
that many of these evangelicals are so
knowledgeable about what is wrong with
these so-called Mhm. cultish people
when they themselves have lost
every
little fraction
of Protestantism. They don't know who
the Antichrist is anymore. They sit at
his table. They eat at his table. They
drink of his wine. They're staggering
from one text to the other. They cannot
interpret Thessalonians. They cannot
interpret Daniel. They don't even preach
about it. They don't go to the Book of
Revelation. It's a closed book when it's
called Revelation. I mean, ridiculous.
And that same criticisms
about Ellen White
comes for 100 years already. Yes. And
it's been refuted and
proven
Books this thing written about it text
for text, but And then they say they've
done
very good research. They're very good
researchers.
Yes. But then in
on one accusation, you can you show
them, but listen, this has been
disproved 50 years already. Where did
you do your research?
when I came into this church,
I of course immediately accepted Ellen
White and took everything for gospel
that she that she wrote.
Threw the Bible aside
and that's why I'm an Adventist. You
believe that? No. You don't believe
that.
Not at all. No. So, do you think I was
very skeptical? Yes. Super skeptical.
Ultra critical. Yes.
Ultra critical.
Don't bring me anything but the Bible.
That's it.
So, I read the Bible and I read it again
and then I read it again and then I
discovered, you know,
I'm reading half a Bible. So, I got rid
of those versions, got another one.
Then I realized realized I was reading a
two two-thirds Bible, got rid of that
one. Finally went to
the real thing and uh read the spirit of
prophecy.
Read all the criticism against it
because I really need an excuse not to
be what I am.
Exactly. And eventually come to the
conclusion
I'm cooked. I've got no choice.
You cannot get away from it. The more
you try to disprove it,
if you really do your research and you
do it well,
I'm sorry, it's going to be the same as
if you really want to disprove the
Bible. Yes.
I mean
when I when I think about how I regarded
the Bible before I became a Christian,
a mythological book,
vaguely interesting,
um maybe have some old folk laws in it
that I can use or whatever.
And now I consider it as the word of
God.
Cast in iron and the gates of hell won't
prevail against it, right? Have they
tried to get rid of that book?
Oh, they're still trying.
There's the key, Martin. They're trying
to get rid of this book.
And they're bringing in a thousand
translations with the biggest load of
nonsense in it that you can imagine.
And even gender-neutral Bibles and
now the Queen James Bible. I mean all
kinds of Bible that that you get in the
world out there.
But they the gates of hell haven't
prevailed against it.
No, it's still standing. The true one
you can still find. Is there anybody
that has faced more criticism other than
the Bible
than Ellen G. White? Nope. All right.
It's actually
it's astounding.
She's the female author that wrote more
than any other female author in the
world.
Yes. And she only had
3 years
of education.
Yes. And
think of it. The most the the person
that wrote the most, but she's not
acknowledged. No. And uh
denigrated.
can say if she was the person that wrote
the most and it wrote a bunch of
nonsense, sure. Well, Blavatsky wrote a
lot.
I've got Blavatsky's books. I don't
know, maybe I should make a little
bonfire at some stage.
But I think it will last for about a
year
because it won't quench so quickly.
But
uh so revered and the biggest load of
rubbish under the sun, but so revered.
So, you know, God permits criticism
because criticism invites inspection.
That's it.
And then the question is once you
sincerely ask for truth,
then
uh you have to come to a conclusion when
you read the criticism.
Now, when you read criticism, most
people say, "Well, therefore I will not
read it."
No, you must take the original and see
whether it stands the test and if it
doesn't,
well,
then It's the same same criteria.
Just a example, if you take for instance
today,
if you read a fact check,
rather fact check it yourself before you
just take what the fact checker Well,
today the fact checker is to me an
indication of what is not so.
That's the thing, so.
So, we continue and today God is still
using his church to make known his
purpose in the earth. Today, the heralds
of the cross are going from city to city
and from land to land preparing the way
for the second advent of Christ.
The standard of God's law is being
exalted. Let's just stop there.
True religion
cannot negate the law No.
because you negate the lawgiver.
If you if you set aside Sinai,
you are setting aside the government of
God.
He who turns his foot from the law, even
his prayer is an abomination.
So, the law must be there. The spirit of
the Almighty is moving upon men's hearts
and those who respond to its influence
become witnesses for God and his truth.
In many places, consecrated men and
women may be seen communicating to each
other the light that has made plain to
them the way of salvation through
Christ.
And as they continue to let their light
shine as did those who were baptized
with the spirit on the day of Pentecost,
they receive more and still more of the
spirit's power.
Thus, the earth is to be lightened with
the glory of God.
So, it's a process that has been ongoing
and the gates of hell have not yet
prevailed against it.
Even in spite of the criticism,
are the writings available? Yes. Can you
freely access them? Yes. On the
internet, you don't even have to buy the
books, right?
It's interesting. All the true
writings, both the Bible and spirit of
prophecy is for available for free. You
can get it.
So, the faith which for centuries was
held and taught by the Waldensian
Christians was in marked contrast to the
false doctrines put forth from Rome.
So, the Waldensian Christians, which by
the way go back to apostolic times,
unlike some of our learned gentlemen who
would rather put it into the Middle Ages
somewhere, right?
Goes back to apostolic times.
And when Rome started its ascendancy,
these people were separate from Rome
right from the beginning.
And if you read Thessalonians, Paul was
warning against this system that would
arise, right?
Yes. Daniel warned against them.
Revelation
expands upon it. Did the reformers
recognize it? Yes. All right. Do they
still recognize it? No. No. No. No.
All right. Will the remnant recognize
it? They have to.
Okay. Will there be those in the remnant
that deny it?
Yes.
Will there be those in the remnant that
rather sit on the plush sofa with the
Antichrist than to acknowledge the
spirit of prophecy? Correct. That will
be so. Does that make this church null
and void? No, because still this church
is the one that the gates of hell will
not prevail against. Not these people.
They will not prevail they will not
stand against the gates of hell. Okay.
So, their religious belief was founded
upon the written word of God. That's a
basic
axiom.
The true system of Christianity.
But those humble peasants in their
obscure retreats, shut away from the
world and bound to daily toil amongst
their flocks and in their vineyards, had
not themselves arrived at the truth in
opposition to the dogmas and heresies of
the apostate church.
Theirs was not a faith newly received.
The religious belief was the inheritance
from their fathers.
They contended for the faith of the
apostolic church.
The faith which was once delivered to
the saints. The church in the wilderness
and not the proud hierarchy enthroned in
the world's great capital was the true
church of Christ, the guardian of the
treasures of truth which God has
committed to his people to be given to
the world. Martin, this is largely based
on Waldensian writings. That's it.
Unless of course you like the modern
stuff that comes out of Jesuit stables.
So, this is the true church. So, the
criteria that you have here
is that
it must be based on the Bible
and you must know which one.
There's another quote
from From Here to Forever.
From the dungeon, the stake, the
scaffold where saints and martyrs
witnessed for the truth, comes down the
centuries the utterance of their faith
and hope.
Being assured of his personal
resurrection,
and consequently of their own at his
coming,
for this cause, says one of these
Christians, they despised death and were
found to be above it.
The Waldensian the Waldenses cherished
the same faith.
Wiclif, Luther, Calvin, Knox, Ridley,
Baxter looked in faith for the Lord's
coming. Such was the hope of the
apostolic church, the church of in the
wilderness, and of the reformers.
Martin Luther said, I hope he doesn't
take another 100 years because the
church will be
Not destroyed.
And
well, it took more than 100 years, 500
years of reformation, and his church is
destroyed.
But the church of God is not destroyed.
No, it's still the true church is still
alive. All right. So, where did the
Waldensians
learn it from? The apostolic.
Yes. Right? From the apostles, right
back to the time of the apostles.
And then where did Wiclif learn it from?
He discovered the scriptures.
Yeah.
Luther, Calvin, Knox, Ridley, Baxter
and they all said they longed for the
Lord's coming.
Did Paul long for the Lord's coming? Oh,
yes. Must it be a feature of the
remnant? Definitely. All right. Advent.
Yeah.
That means Second coming of Christ.
Must be a feature.
By the middle of the 18th century,
the new world had received
representatives not only of the major
reformation churches, Lutheran,
Reformed, and Anglican,
but had also been seeded with all the
rediscovered truths brought by the
evangelicals seeking freedom of worship
that had been denied them in Britain and
on the continent.
So, Martin, if you discovered truth,
then you were persecuted.
If you discovered adult baptism in the
Bible, you were persecuted. If you
discovered the Sabbath in the Bible, you
were persecuted. So, where did these
people flee to?
To the United States. So, there was a
crucible
of all the doctrines that had been
discovered and rejected on the mainland.
Yes.
In the United States. And also it's
important to know it was rediscovered.
So, it was just lost. It was the
original. It's it's like in the Old
Testament times when the book of the law
was lost.
Yes. And they had to make a thorough
search.
And they found it.
And they read it in the presence of the
king and he tore his clothes and wept
sorely because
everything that was wrong They were
doing. They were doing it. And they read
it in the book of the law.
So, Martin, these truths had to be
rediscovered and then God had to somehow
gather
this truth from this denomination, that
truth from that movement, that truth
from that one, bring them all together
in a final movement.
What a brilliant plan.
And so he started the Advent movement.
It was not the Adventists, it was a
evangelical movement amongst all the
churches. Exactly. And all of those
people came out and became
Adventists, not Seventh-day Adventists,
but people longing for the second coming
of Christ. It's a prerequisite.
It is. It's a prerequisite of the last
church, or the true church.
Has to have that longing. And then what
happened? Once all of these thousands,
some 50,000 of them, from every single
denomination had come together
based on thorough study of prophecy and
the Bible,
then a great disappointment,
a great scattering.
And from 50,000 we went down to 50,
right?
And they went back to the Bible
and then they discovered
their mistake, the sanctuary message.
And then all of these truths came
together. The Sabbath came into the mix.
The state of the dead came into the mix.
Uh the sanctuary message was added. Now,
the sanctuary message, is it a new
doctrine? No, like you said, it's
rediscovered. It's been the same
doctrine since Jesus' time, since
actually
the beginning. From the beginning, the
whole Old Testament is sanctuary based,
right?
So, here was a a mega discovery that had
been lost.
And it explained the plan of salvation.
It explained what sin is, what the
consequences of sin is, what repentance
is, what the recipe for salvation is,
and what the ultimate fate Mhm. of the
sinner and the transgressor is going to
be, right? All there in type.
And now, finally, there was a movement
that could take all of these truths. And
the pioneers wrote about it and put it
together.
And the gates of hell went berserk.
And they are trying to prevail against
it. But there's a promise.
So, Martin, if you study your Bible and
you look at the features that define the
remnant,
you will find that they keep the
commandments of God.
Revelation 12:17, here are they that
keep the commandments. It's
it's a given. It has to be there.
They have the testimony of Jesus. Same
verse.
We are defining it in
Revelation chapter 19 as the spirit of
prophecy. They must have the prophetic
gift that was given to the early
disciples has to be restored in the
remnant.
They have the faith of Jesus.
The faith of Jesus is recorded in this
good book.
And did Jesus believe every word of the
Bible? Yes. Mhm? Every single word.
Yeah, there are people that believe he
quoted from the Septuagint.
Which is not only a
a fossil,
but is a missing link that has never
been found, right?
Other than in Origen's writings.
So, Jesus had the faith of Jesus.
Yes.
He had the faith that every word, man
does not live from bread alone, but by
Every every word that proceeds out of
the mouth of God.
It had to arise at a particular time
because Revelation chapter 12 describes
the church in the wilderness,
the 1,260
day prophecy.
And at the end of that period, after
1798,
then must the way be prepared for the
coming of the remnant. And between 1798
and 1844,
you had the great awakening. Mhm.
Mhm?
Isn't that interesting?
Re-studying of the prophecies.
Back to the Bible, back to the
prophecies, and out of that
must come the remnant that keeps the
commandments of God, has the testimony
and the faith of Jesus. Exactly. So, it
has to be sometime after this period and
before the great disappointment
when there was a scattering of this
great reawakening movement,
right? That had taken place in every
denomination. That's interesting.
Not one.
And then the features of this remnant
that keep the commandments, that have
the testimony, that have the faith of
Jesus, that arises at the right time, is
that it must preach the three angels'
messages. Yes.
And that it must be a worldwide
movement.
Martin,
find me the church that does this.
There's only one. There's only one. And
whether I like it or not, I can say I
want to follow Jesus. All right, I have
the faith of Jesus.
Do you keep the commandments? Do you
have the testimony? Do you belong to a
movement that arises at the right time?
And do you belong to the movement that
preaches the three angels' messages?
If you don't, then you sit with the same
problem. State for instance that
that the disciples.
If there was a person that said he
wanted to be a follower of Jesus, but he
didn't join the disciples, would it what
would that help?
He wouldn't So, he would go on his own
and walk Didn't Jesus say follow me?
That's it. Now, did Jesus lead out the
people?
Did he call it his church?
Yes. Mhm? And didn't he even say the
gates of hell would not prevail against
it? So, does he have a church?
He does have a church.
He must have a church, and the church
must be based on the true message.
And you cannot base your feelings about
the church on the members
because if you looked at Judas, you
would run from the church.
Exactly.
Or the occasional failings of the
disciples.
Here's a another statement from Letters
and Manuscripts volume 12, The Lord is
the shield of his people.
He alone must be our strength, our
sufficiency. He says to his people,
"Fear not.
I am he that liveth and was dead and
behold, I am alive forevermore." Quoting
Revelation, "God is in the midst of her.
She shall not be moved. God shall help
her
and that right early." Quoting Psalms
46:5.
Our relation with God must be of a
distinct character as a people waiting
and watching for the Son of Man to come
in the clouds of heaven.
But isn't it the wicked servant that
says the Lord delays his coming? Yep.
So, do we have a lot of wicked servants
amongst us? Yeah, and
maybe they don't even realize it. And
maybe they don't realize they don't even
realize they're wicked. They must
realize
And why are they wicked? Because they
not looking forward to Jesus' coming, so
that means they're not preparing. Or
they're clinging to something. That's
it. So, if you're preparing
then you have to start getting rid of
things
because this narrow road don't have
space for baggage. Okay. So, Martin, if
you have this mindset is it possible
that you might drag others down with
you?
And put them into a state of
complacency?
If you stand on top of the table and I'm
down here and you're trying to pull me
up, is it easier for you to pull me up
or for me to pull you down? Huh? That's
true.
You've got
uh what they call gravity on your side.
The church whom God loves and keeps as
his commandment-keeping people is as
precious as the apple of his eye.
That's where our title comes from.
The Lord says, "Do you know your
privileges? Have you faith in God? Have
you a living connection with God? Do we
sense his love as light in the morning
in the midst of the church militant
feeding each lamp with the golden oil of
his grace, of his love?"
So,
the Lord has a church
and he's in the midst of it.
Was he in the midst of his disciples?
Was there a Judas? Yes.
The world has no right to doubt the
truth of Christianity because there are
unworthy members in the church.
And this is a big problem today because
many people feel that they want to
withhold their support for the church
because there are unworthy members in
the church. Martin, what would happen if
I become an unworthy member next week or
next month or next year or in 10 years?
Mhm.
What if I was fake
and was pretending to be a worthy member
when I was actually a wolf in sheep's
clothing?
Does that make the church wrong? No. If
you take
you also always mention Aaron.
Yes. If you wanted to withheld your
money, your tithe, because Aaron was
there
would that have been right? No, it would
not have been right.
Just to clarify it because
when he was making the golden calf, he
was totally wrong. Yes, of course he was
wrong.
But eventually he came right.
But he did it out of weakness, right?
See, so you can never
learn what the consequences are so that
next time he could be stronger. So, your
giving
back to your church
mustn't be based on anything that you
have your eye visible eyes on. Okay.
Nor should Christians become
disheartened because of these false
brethren.
How was it with the early church?
Ananias and Sapphira joined themselves
to the disciples. Simon Magus was
baptized.
Demas, who forsook Paul, had been
counted a believer. Judas Iscariot was
numbered with the apostles.
The Redeemer does not want to lose one
soul. His experience with Judas is
recorded to show his long patience
with perverse human nature.
And he bids us bear with it as he has
borne. He has said that false brethren
will be found in the church till the
close of time.
So, Martin, we have no excuse when we
say we don't want to be with this church
because this one or that one or this
group or this leadership or even the
highest level in the church contains
brethren that are false brethren.
They will be there till the close of
time.
And it doesn't give us the right to call
the remnant Babylon, either.
God has a church upon the earth who are
his chosen people who keep the
commandments.
He's leading not a stray offshoot, not
one here and one there, but a people.
The truth is a sanctifying power, but
the church militant is not the church
triumphant.
There are tares amongst the wheat. "Wilt
thou then that we go and gather them
up?" was the question of the servants.
But the master said, "Nay, lest while
you gather up the tares, you root up
also the wheat with them."
The gospel net draws not only good fish,
but bad ones as well and the Lord only
knows who are his. We must not allow
modern trends that tend to tear the
church apart.
We must always remember how
Jesus dealt with him.
And it was right at the end, at
the crucifixion
that Judas was actually exposed.
Right at the end there. There was no
And that's so important because if you
look at everything now, all these
offshoots Yes. they look so wonderful
because
preach such wonderful message, but
they're tearing the body apart.
That's the problem.
Because with the disciples, did they
like Judas? They loved him. They thought
he was wonderful.
Yeah.
Okay, the Lord has not given you a
message to call the Seventh-day
Adventist Babylon.
Now, some
would like to call certain categories
within the Adventist Church Babylon.
So, you might say this conference has
become Babylon.
Some will go so far as to say the
General Conference has become Babylon.
Well, I will readily admit that there
must be Babylonians amongst them.
And uh maybe also in prominent
positions.
But as we said, maybe some of them are
Aaron.
So, I may not judge.
And I cannot call the church Babylon.
To call the people of God to come out of
her, all the reasons you may present
cannot have weight with me on this
subject because the Lord has given me
decided light that is opposed to such a
message.
It's like calling the apostolic church
Babylon.
Right?
Yeah. Paul and Because all of those
other people had joined themselves to
that church.
No.
This church has the truth.
And it is the truth that is to bind us
together.
Mhm.
God is leading out a people. He has a
chosen people, a church on the earth
whom he has made the depositaries of his
law.
He has committed to them sacred trust
and eternal truth to be given to the
world.
He would reprove and correct them.
The message to the Laodiceans is
applicable to Seventh-day Adventists who
have had great light
and have not walked in the light.
It is those who have made great
profession
but have not kept in step with their
leader
and that leader is Jesus Christ, no one
else.
That will be spewed out of his mouth
unless they repent.
The message to pronounce the Seventh-day
Adventist Church Babylon and call the
people of God out of her does not come
from any heavenly messenger or any human
agent inspired by the Spirit of God.
There is no church after Laodicea. No.
And if this message applies to this
church
I cannot come out of her. No, so there's
no coming out
of So, what do I want to do? Pack my
little Spirit of Prophecy books and my
Bible and go and
sit on a new anthill
and scream all by myself?
No, because I didn't invent this
message. No.
I'm not the inventor thereof.
I'm just a custodian that has inherited
something. Mhm. And if the others don't
like the inheritance, that's their
problem. Let them go and scream on their
anthill.
But I won't listen to them.
The Lord has a specific work for
everyone
of his people to do. The work is not to
be confined to one or two created
centers
but it is far-reaching.
This is the beauty of this church. You
and I can sit here
and we can be part of this movement.
Mhm.
We do not have to take our instructions
from anyone No. other than the Bible and
the Spirit of Prophecy.
Right? Men of God's appointment are to
fulfill their obligations to God to do
his service, bearing not the
requirements of men,
but through diligent searching of the
scriptures, realizing their individual
responsibility. I don't have a pope. No.
And I don't have a coach. No. And I
don't want a pope, and I don't want a
coach.
But I want the Bible, the leader. And I
want it to correct my faults, and it I
want it to tell me where I am not in
harmony with it.
And I want God to help me to correct it.
You see, maybe this is also where the
problem comes in.
Your attitude towards how the structure
of this church that we're talking about
has to work.
Yes. Because if you look at it from a
worldly perspective, you always want a
leader. Yes.
But this is the problem. This church is
not a worldly church. It's not It
doesn't work on those principles.
But there are some that believe that it
should.
And that's why when they get unhappy
with this structure, they want to leave
it to go and build another structure.
Correct. So, now let's let's get just a
little bit closer without being too
direct.
But if someone dares to ask a question,
"Excuse me, are we working in right
lines here?"
Uh
"Is this the way that God would have us
move forward?"
And somebody says in a leadership
position, "You may not ask that
question." Then you are transgressing
God's law.
That's it. You are transgressing God's
law. And you can safely ignore such an
individual because God has never said
that you may not question this, that, or
the other.
They are to watch, to pray, to seek
counsel of God, and be prepared to place
before those whom they are seeking to
save the pure,
unadulterated motives,
which he has revealed to them as his
stewards to set before others to induce
them to work for the master. So, Martin,
what you have been given to set before
others is a package of truth.
You place it on the plate,
and you tell people to eat it.
So, when they eat it, they internalize
it,
they study it, they investigate it in
the light of the great light.
Mhm.
And if it is found wanting, you spew it
out.
And if it is truth,
you digest it, and you keep it.
Yeah.
It is not in the order of God that a few
men shall manage the great interest
throughout the field. I'm just putting
these quotes in to make people see what
the true perspective is.
Nobody
has the right to say, "I'm in a position
of leadership. You shall do as I say."
Mhm.
Excuse me, we have a leader.
You know, like the church in Scotland
told the church in England,
"We have no king
other than Jesus."
And the king of England decided to make
war with Scotland on the basis of that.
Yeah.
And uh
he experienced quite a backlash. You
see, so we might even get to war within
this church Yes. because of the
sentiment that you've just mentioned.
If truth is threatened,
then let there be even war.
Many of the men who have acted as
counselors in board and council meeting
need to be weeded out.
Other men should take their places, for
their
God. Their plans and devisings are not
after the order of God. The same men
have been kept in office as directors of
boards until under their own management
and their own opinions, common fire is
used in the place of sacred fire of
God's own kindling.
These men are no more called Israel, but
supplanters.
They've worked themselves so long
instead of being worked by the Holy
Spirit.
And they know not that the spirit impels
them to action.
So, Martin, will we have such situations
within our church?
Especially as we near the end of of
time.
All right. Now, some people will despair
because it seems as if matters are not
corrected.
But didn't we read that God is
long-suffering? That's it.
Not willing that any should perish.
He's still the leader. Okay. So, let's
let's investigate this further.
Review and Herald, January the 8th,
written in 1884.
Not all the names that stand registered
in the church books will at last appear
in the Lamb's Book of Life. There are
tares amongst the wheat.
There are betrayers, accusers,
traitors in the camp.
It was so in Israel's time, it will be
so with this church. These will wound,
misrepresent,
falsely accuse you.
They are false brethren, meddlesome,
indiscreet, stumbling blocks to others.
They are doing a work for Satan far more
successfully than if they were not
connected with the church.
Some who have not spiritual discernment
will fail to distinguish between the
false and the true, and will highly
esteem those who have no connection with
God.
Martin, isn't that an interesting
statement?
So, can we expect some highly esteemed
individuals within the church that have
no connection with God? They rather sit
within within an ecumenical council and
think as those people do, right?
Those who have been indifferent and
neglectful, and have failed to grow in
grace and in the knowledge of the truth
will be deceived. They do not comprehend
the first principles of doctrine and
experience, which secure to man the
perfection of Christian character.
The great
driving force
when I discovered this truth
was that I had to
come out of her.
I had to separate myself.
Change. I had to totally change.
Now, Martin, isn't it counterproductive
if I want to go back
and make a compromise? That's why I
sometimes get so hot under the collar
when I see
the things that I left behind and I had
to get rid of seeping into the church,
and people wanting to use that to lure
other people into the church.
Yeah, I listened to a little sermon the
other day,
and the man said, "When I looked for the
world, I found them I found it in the
church.
And when I looked for the church, I
found it in the world."
That's true, eh?
That's it. Yeah. So, once you've made
the decision that you have to separate
yourself
from that which is Babylon,
then even to contemplate going back and
smoozing with Babylon is
incomprehensible.
And here's a very important statement.
That's why we bolded it. There is no
need to doubt,
to be fearful that the work will not
succeed because there's a promise, "The
gates of hell will not prevail against
it." God is at the head of the work, and
he will set everything in order.
If matters need adjusting at the head of
the work,
God will attend to that.
And work to right every wrong. Let us
have faith that God is going to carry
the noble ship which bears the people of
God safely into the port.
So, God is going to right the wrongs.
So, does that mean I must right the
wrongs?
No. And unfortunately for us, we always
will ask, "Why does he take so long to
sort this out?" To sort it out. But if
it needs adjustment at the head of the
work, he will do it, right? He's
long-suffering.
Okay. So, if we go to the writings of
Paul, we read in journeyings often.
He's talking about his life within the
church.
In perils in waters,
in perils of robbers,
in perils of mine own countrymen,
in perils with the heathen, in perils in
the city, in perils in the wilderness,
in perils in the sea. And then he puts
the cherry on top. In perils amongst
false brethren.
That's his cherry. So, why should be any
different for us?
Cannot.
Cannot be different.
Isaiah chapter 9, "Therefore the Lord
will cut off from Israel head and tail,
branch and rush in one day."
Did he cut off Judas?
Yes.
What thou do?
Quickly.
That's why one day go.
Uh Martin, what did Judas go and do?
He went to betray Jesus.
Aha.
So when the Lord cuts off the head and
he says, "What thou doest, do it
quickly." What are they going to do?
They're going to betray him.
They're going to betray Jesus. Yes. And
they're going to betray him in the form
of his people. That's it. Who have the
faith of Jesus.
Right?
Because the faith of Jesus is irritating
to Judas.
And it will be irritating to the false
brethren.
But Judas was actually thinking that he
was doing God a favor because he wanted
to twist the arm of God so that Jesus
would reveal himself as the Messiah so
that he could be the prime minister.
Yeah.
Mhm? So that he could be seen as
somebody important to the world. So
Martin, who is the head and who is the
tail? The ancient and honorable.
He is the head.
And the prophet that teaches lies, he is
the tail.
For the leaders of this people cause
them to err and they that are led of
them are destroyed. That was the
situation then.
And in many cases it will be the
situation today. Martin, do you think
it's
it's important for us to define the
ancient and the honorable? No, God can
do that.
God can do that because we would
probably mess it up, right? So let's
leave it to God.
So that's why we have the statement in
the Acts of Apostles. Look to God.
During ages of spiritual darkness, the
church of God has been as a city set on
a hill.
From age to age through successive
generations, the pure doctrines of
heaven
have been unfolding within its borders.
Enfeebled and defective as it may
appear, the church
is the one object upon which God bestows
in a special sense his supreme regard.
It is the theater of his grace in which
he delights to reveal his power to
transform hearts.
And Martin,
this may sound strange,
but to many
it might seem humiliating
to join the church. But Moses had to be
humbled.
And therefore,
you have to delight in this activity so
that you can have a transformed heart.
Now, Ezekiel describes a terrible
shaking within the church
in chapters 5, 8, and 9.
And in chapter 9 verse 4 we read, "And
the Lord said unto him, 'Go through the
midst of the city, through the midst of
Jerusalem and set a mark upon the
forehead of the men that sigh and that
cry for all the abominations
that be done in the midst thereof.'"
So Martin, who are the ones who receive
the mark or the seal of God?
The ones that cry for the abominations
that being done in the midst. Those that
actually care for the church.
Okay, so
they must realize that there are
abominations, otherwise they wouldn't be
crying and sighing, right?
If I think everything is hunky-dory,
Mhm. then maybe I'm not looking deep
enough.
Maybe I'm not uh
discerning what's really happening,
right?
Now, we're supposed to look at chapters
5, 8, and 9. Now, we're not going to go
through chapters 5, 8, and 9
in their totality, but it's just
fascinating when you look at it
as to what the situation was. Ezekiel
says in chapter 5 verse 1,
"And thou, son of man, take thee a sharp
knife.
Take thee a barber's razor and cause it
to pass upon thine head and upon thy
beard.
And then take thee balances to weigh and
divide the hair."
Martin, did you do something like
like that?
And then it tells us what will happen.
"Thou shalt burn with fire a third part
in the midst of the city."
So the hair becomes
a symbol of God's people.
He says, you know, that he even counts
the hairs upon your head.
All right. God is counting considerably
less than he did in the past when it
comes to me. Yeah, well.
Well, you you you you you've you've
fulfilled the first verse, yeah.
He counts the hair of your head when
you're young.
Okay.
"So you shall burn with fire a third
part in the midst of the city when the
days of the siege are fulfilled.
And thou shalt take a third part and
smite about it with a knife.
And the third part thou shalt scatter in
the wind.
And I will draw out the sword after
them."
Mhm.
And then verse 3 is very interesting.
"Thou shalt also take thereof a few in
number."
That's rather sad, huh?
It always works like that. Yeah.
There's you know,
take
every time Israel
was a few amongst the nations. And so
it's carried on right through up until
there's a remnant. It's not the
majority.
It's a sad state. "So you shall take
thereof a few in number and bind them in
thy skirts and take them again and cast
them into the midst of the fire."
So even amongst those, there will be a
sifting.
Martin, so basically he can shout,
"What's left?"
So if you read verse 12, "A third part
of these shall die with a pestilence.
And with a famine shall they be consumed
in the midst." Martin, is the world
experiencing
pestilence and is there a famine coming?
Definitely if you even take it
spiritually. Yes, but even physically.
Physically as well.
"All right. And a third part shall fall
by the sword
round about thee and I will scatter a
third part
into all the winds
and I will draw out the sword after
them."
Now, wind in the Bible is also a symbol
of war, right?
So we are expecting great calamities and
we'll be looking at those in a future
discussion
when we go into current events again.
Now, if you go to uh chapter 8
and we read the first verse, the second
half of the verse, "The elders of Judah
sat before me that the hand of the Lord
God fell there upon me."
"And then I beheld and lo, a likeness as
to the appearance of fire."
So he has a vision like John had. And
like Daniel had. He sees
Jesus.
And then when we drop down to verse 3,
the last portion,
it says there, "And he looked towards
the north."
Cuz he's he's in Jerusalem to the door
of the inner gate. And he looks towards
the north and there was the seat of the
image of jealousy.
That's amazing. The image of jealousy.
Now, Martin, what caused the rebellion
in heaven?
Jealousy. Jealousy.
So there's an image of jealousy. One of
the great problems within the church.
And he's looking towards the north. Mhm,
too. That's the seat of God, right?
And there's jealousy.
Jealousy is a is a killer Mhm.
in amongst God's people.
And this image of jealousy sits in the
north. It's trying to
eradicate the throne of God.
Mhm?
And then he says there will be greater
abominations.
And in verse 7 he says there's a hole in
the wall.
The law. There's a breach in the law of
God.
Hey, isn't that interesting?
And there's idolatry within the church.
And if you read further, there is
a greater abomination. There are women
weeping for Tammuz.
I think some of these people are so
involved with Catholicism
that they are also weeping
for Tammuz.
Verse 16.
"And he brought me into the inner court
of the Lord's house house and behold, at
the door of the temple of the Lord
between the porch and the altar were
about five and 20 men with their backs
towards the temple of the Lord and their
faces towards the east and they
worshiped the sun towards the east."
Martin, 25 people. That's the 25 elders
that might be involved in some form of
sun worship.
And when the time comes for Sunday law,
which is sun worship,
maybe
they will try to force the hand to see
if they can bring about a change.
Persuade.
All right. Now, it doesn't define who
they are,
but it is the prominent people.
There amongst them are people.
But as we said last time,
there's always someone who will hide
God's prophets in a cave.
And so you could read it all,
and then chapter 9 of course,
from verse 4, "And the Lord said unto
him,
to this
angel with the inkhorn,
"Go through the midst of the city,
through the midst of Jerusalem, and set
a mark on the forehead of the men that
sigh and cry
for all the abominations that be done in
the midst thereof."
And to the others he said in mine
hearing, "Go ye after him through the
city and smite.
Let not your eyes spare, neither have ye
pity. Slay utterly old and young, both
maids and little children and women, but
come not near any man upon whom is the
mark, and begin at my sanctuary."
Then they began at the ancient men
which were before the house.
I don't think we need to clarify what we
read. No.
But this is a serious situation.
Does this make the church Babylon? No.
No.
So can we say, Martin, that the remnant
church will be brought into great trial
and distress.
Definitely, and it will grow worse and
worse as we near the second coming.
Those who keep the commandments of God
and the faith of Jesus
will feel the ire of the dragon and his
hosts. Satan numbers the world as his
subjects.
He has gained control of the apostate
churches, but there is a little company
that is resisting his supremacy.
If he could blot them from the earth,
his triumph would be complete.
As he influenced the heathen nations to
destroy Israel,
so in the near future he will stir up
the wicked powers of the earth to
destroy the people of God.
Martin, was this just written for her
time?
No, because the Bible
states the same. Okay. And that was
written for the end. All will be
required to render obedience to human
edicts in violation of the divine law.
Those who will be true to God and to
duty will be betrayed. It's a given.
By parents, brethren, kinsfolk,
and friends.
Martin, just because this is prophesied,
doesn't mean that I must leave the
church.
On the contrary,
those who are true to God will be
menaced, denounced, proscribed.
Who?
Those
that are true to God. All right.
And our greatest
problem will come from within. Mhm. We
have more to fear from within than from
without, right?
They will be betrayed by parents,
brethren, kinsfolk, and friends, even
unto death.
Their only hope is in the mercy of God.
Their only defense will be prayer. As
Joshua pleaded before the angel, so the
remnant church with brokenness of heart
and unfaltering faith
will plead for pardon and deliverance
through Jesus their advocate. They are
fully conscious of the sinfulness of
their lives.
They see their weakness and
unworthiness, and they are ready to
despair.
Are they going through Jacob's trouble?
Mhm. Yes.
Did we discuss it previously?
Yes. And even before the Jacob's trouble
time, you will already start going
through this and looking to despair.
Okay. So Martin, is it time
to realize our weakness and
unworthiness? Constantly, every day. And
when you see apostasy in high places,
uh is that a reason to despair?
No.
But is it a reason for introspection?
Yes. Cuz the time is near. And make sure
that you're not part of it.
So let's have a look at how God deals
with these issues. Daniel's
interpretation of the king's dream. This
is the one
where Nebuchadnezzar dreamt about a tree
that was going to be cut off, right?
And now I Nebuchadnezzar praise and
extol and honor the King of heaven, all
whose works are truth, and his ways
judgment, and those that walk in pride
he's able to abase.
These predictions of the infinite one
recorded in the prophetic page and
traced on the pages of history were
given to demonstrate that God is the
ruling power in the affairs of this
world. He changes the times and seasons.
He removes kings and sets up kings to
fulfill his own purpose.
We must not despair within this church.
Isaiah 8:4 says, "They have set up
kings,
but not by me.
They have made princes, and I knew it
not. Of their silver and their gold have
they made them idols
that they may be cut off."
So God is in control even
if
there are
even amongst the leadership false
brethren.
"Set the trumpet to thy mouth. He shall
come as an eagle against the house of
the Lord because they have transgressed
my covenant,
trespassed against my law. Israel shall
cry unto me, 'My God, we know thee.'
Israel has cast off the thing that is
good. The enemy shall pursue him.
They have set up kings,
but not by me. They have made princes,
and I knew it not.
Of their silver and gold they have made
them idols that they may be cut off. I
have written to him the great thing of
my law, but they were counted as a
strange thing." So here the spirit of
prophecy word for word repeats what the
Bible has to say.
So there's absolute harmony cuz it's the
same thing.
100%. So Martin, the bottom line is we
read in 5 manuscripts released that many
will go from us.
Giving heed to seducing spirits, a
superficial faith
results in a superficial experience.
The light given me has been very
forcible that many would go out from us,
giving heed to seducing spirits and
doctrines of devils.
So does this now take what we read in
Ezekiel
chapters 5 and 8 and 9 and apply it to
our time? Yes. Absolutely. And the thing
is this
seducing spirits and doctrines of
devils,
it sounds like it will look evil, but it
won't. It will look as if this is the
truth according to them. If it didn't,
then how could it be seducing? That's
the thing.
The Lord desires that every soul who
claims to believe the truth shall have
an intelligent knowledge of what is
truth.
False prophets will arise and will
deceive many. Everything is to be shaken
that can be shaken. You already know
that when they say, "This is Babylon,
come out," it's a false prophet. That's
the problem. That's it. That should be
your big red flag. So they can put all
these nice quotes in Bible and try and
disprove that
the church is wrong and Babylon.
It cannot be.
Then does it not become everyone to
understand the reason of our faith?
In place of having so many sermons,
there should be more close searching of
the word of God, opening the scriptures
text by text, searching for the strong
evidence that sustain the fundamental
doctrines that have brought us where we
now are, even upon the platform of
eternal truth. Martin, when they start
denying these fundamental doctrines of
the church,
and already started in the forward
movement and before that even,
believe them not. They ran, but they
were not sent. Yeah.
When trees without fruit are cut down as
cumberers of the ground,
when multitudes of false brethren are
distinguished from the true,
then the hidden ones will be revealed to
view,
and with hosannas ranged under the
banner of Christ.
I think they're hiding in caves.
They're scared of Jezebel.
No, they're more scared of Ahab Yeah.
Mhm. Who executes what Jezebel wants.
That's it.
So we've got to be careful of those that
uh that rule, that want to tell us what
Jezebel wants, right?
Those who have been timid and
self-distrustful will declare themselves
openly for Christ and his truth.
The most weak and hesitating in the
church will be as David,
willing to do and dare. The deeper the
night for God's people, the more
brilliant the stars.
Satan will sorely harass the faithful,
but in the name of Jesus they will come
off more than conquerors. Then
will the church of Christ appear fair as
the moon, clear as the sun, and terrible
as an army with banners.
So my appeal to the people is don't
despair.
Don't despair.
I have always said from the beginning,
get yourself a pot of super glue.
Paint your posterior
and sit in the church
and wait for God
to do the work.
Because there is a great gathering that
is coming.
There's a great shaking.
That's it.
And after the great shaking, a great
gathering. Not of those who've been
shaken out.
Mhm.
There will be another gathering. And we
read about it in the book of Isaiah
chapter 49 and 16. Thus says the Lord
God, behold, I will lift up mine hand to
the Gentiles
and set up my standard to the people.
The standard, the law of God, the
Sabbath.
And they shall bring their sons in their
arms and their daughters shall be
carried upon their shoulders. Isaiah 60,
arise, shine, for thy light is come and
the glory of the Lord is risen upon thee
and behold, the darkness shall cover the
earth and gross darkness the people, but
the Lord shall arise upon thee and his
glory shall be seen upon thee. Martin,
can we expect the entire collective
church to change and suddenly become
light?
No.
No. The Bible tells us there will be a
shaking. There will be a remnant of a
remnant.
And they will receive this light.
And then the Gentiles shall come to thy
light and the kings to the brightness of
thy rising.
Lift up thine eyes round about thee and
see, all they gather themselves
together. They come to thee.
Thy sons shall come from far, thy
daughters shall be nursed at thy side.
Then shalt thou see and flow together
and thine heart shall fear and be
enlarged because the abundance of the
sea shall be converted unto thee.
The forces of the Gentiles shall come
unto thee. What an amazing promise.
The abundance of the sea, that's the
nations. Mhm.
Shall be converted. When it says thy
heart shall fear, it doesn't mean you
will be afraid.
Right. You will be overawed with what
God is doing and it will be enlarged.
You will feel so elated.
This is the promise.
But first there's a shaking. Yes, and
despair.
So when this time of trouble comes,
every case is decided.
There's no longer probation, no longer
mercy for the impenitent.
So these people will come in.
Probation closes.
Yeah.
So first the shaking
Mhm.
then the gathering
then the close of probation.
Now, this gathering
sometimes takes place because of a
testimony given in a court of law where
you stand accused.
Yeah.
And you have to give a reason for the
hope within you.
Must you know the reason for the hope
within you? Exactly. You cannot stand if
you don't know it.
The seal of the living God is upon his
people.
This small remnant
Mhm. Not big.
No, small remnant. Unable to defend
themselves in the deadly conflict with
the powers of earth that are marshaled
by the dragon host make God their
defense.
The decree has been passed by the
highest earthly authority that they
shall worship the beast and receive his
mark on the pain of persecution and
death.
And
they will also be brethren
standing with these accusers.
Yes, they will be your greatest
accusers.
Luke 21:28.
So what if one of the accusers happens
to be your pastor, for example?
You might need to know more about this
book than he does. Exactly.
And when these things begin to come to
pass, then look up and lift up your
heads for your redemption draweth nigh.
Martin, I am personally convinced
that the end is
at the door.
I see the signs.
I see it even within the church.
And rather than despair
look up.
Lift up your head. Your redemption
draweth nigh. This is God's church. It's
going to go through to the kingdom.
But we are living in these culminating
moments of earth's history.
And I am expecting God to intervene
and set matters right even at the head
very very soon. Shall we pray?
Please.
Heavenly Father
what a tremendous journey
to travel in this gospel ship
with all those storms raging
the image of jealousy within
the waves bashing from out without
and seemingly the master is at asleep.
But he is not asleep.
He is in full control
and very soon he will take the wheel
and we will be sailing to that eternal
shore.
Help us to be part of this remnant
movement is my prayer in Jesus name.
Amen.